Let's hear from some of the people in
our audience. We are taking calls today
via discord. You can join The David Pakman
Show discord at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord. It is a great place to be. Let's go first
here to let's go to Stephanie from Richardson,
Texas, which has just announced they are
opening everything. They are stopping masking.
They are doing so many different things.
Stephanie, what's going on down there?
Hi. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Wonderful. Excellent. I love your
show. I discovered you during quarantine. I
want to start by saying that. Thank you for
taking my call. Pleasure. Yeah. I'm so glad you
took my call. This is the first time I've done
something like this. And I am calling to speak on
being absolutely beside myself for the unmasking
mandate. I'm a little freaked out actually go.
So was my question on this, Stephanie. My
my belief was in a segment I did when when the
news broke about this, I said, this is crazy,
irresponsible. You know, only seven percent of
Texans are vaccinated. It's just far too early.
However, I have a sense that the people that
don't care about the guidelines were already
ignoring them in Texas anyway, and that
people that do are going to keep wearing
masks anyway. Like, is there some truth to that?
Yeah, that's actually my hope. I really I'm hoping
that as startling as the news was, I'm really
hoping that we will maintain as we have then.
Right. As you've seen and a lot of the reports,
it is a lot like that. People who aren't going to
mask aren't going to mask, even though there was
a mandate in place. And those of us who've chosen
to keep doing that will keep doing that.
My only my only real concern is that
the Texas education agency that's run
by a software person, not an educator,
hopefully will follow the guidelines and
keep them as mandates in place at school.
Because I do have a daughter in middle schools.
Yeah, I'm really hoping that that will be the
they'll follow the guidelines and be smart
about it, because obviously, you know, a lot
of parents are concerned about that. But yeah, I
mean, that's kind of my hope, too, though. That
is that a lot of the people who are continuing
to follow the guidelines will keep doing that.
I don't think those of us who've been doing all
of a sudden, oh, yeah, this is not you know,
I'm still not going to go to restaurants.
I'm still not going to go unmasked. So it's
just like I'm hoping the rest of us are
going to be in the same boat basically.
Now, when you say that a lot of people
were ignoring the mass guidelines anywhere
anyway, in some states with mask mandates,
if you go into a business without a mask,
you get kicked out in Texas. Is it more of
like a look the other way type of thing?
Yeah, basically, yeah. It's kind of like upsetting
because I've been in places that have, like, you
know, the massive mandate requirement on the door.
But then I go in there and I see people without a
mask and fortunately not like. It's less often
than not. Yes, I should say, but it's like when
I see someone, I'll turn around and go the other
way and do my leg mostly at the grocery store,
and I'll just shop in another aisle. But, yeah,
it's not I'm not seeing any of those things that
people post on social media or whatever about
people freaking out about masks in stores. They
do that because I don't like that store owners
don't do a lot to enforce it. So it's like that's
a little frustrating. But again, like I said, it's
not happening all the time, so that's good. And I
don't see any real drama, but I just kind of go
in a different aisle and continue my shopping.
And let me ask you this. Are there
places where if you go in with a mask,
you are looked at like you're the crazy one?
Yeah, absolutely. Actually, it's funny because
I mostly I do research and I shop at low hours
and I and low capacity hours or whatever,
and I and I go places that have a mandate. But
my husband goes to a place locally that there's
an independently owned business and the guy
does not require you wear a mask and he says
he'll walk in there and yell like I take
it off. It's like I'm not going to see.
That's crazy. That's crazy.
Take it off. It's like he's kind of half joking,
but not really. But he knows it's like a bizarre,
you know, so he's not going to like, you know,
he's going to my husband could do he he's going
to do. But like I said, I wouldn't go in there.
Right. Right, right. Right, right, right.
Like, there's people there. Just it's just
it's so crazy. And there's people that just
like it's like I my whole attitude this whole
time has been it's like the least thing you
can do is just the minimum requirements.
Yeah. It's such an easy thing.
It's like it just, you know,
OK, you want to open businesses make sense,
but they're just wearing a mask is so easy.
Well, listen, Stephanie, thanks for the update
on what's going on down there and stay safe.
Thanks. You, too. I appreciate it. All right.
Stephanie from Texas, great to hear from her